[Musique]
donc ceux qui sont d'accord pour le
mouvement
peut-être qu'ils sont pas ils seront
travail pourront pas on a tous un gilet
jaune bagnols foutais là en évidence sur
le tableau de bord toute la semaine la
fin jusqu'au 17
un petit code couleur pour montrer que
vous êtes d'accord avec nous avec le
mouvement et qui est chaud qui est pas
chose c'était le 24 octobre dernier à
cet homme ghislain cot a relancé l'idée
d'un gilet jaune pour manifester contre
le gouvernement français contre
l'augmentation du coût de la vie
il est avec nous aujourd'hui alors que
l'acte 5 est en cours à paris dans
différentes villes en france malgré les
appels du gouvernement à suspendre le
mouvement le scooter bonjour bonjour je
viens oui vous êtes vous à narbonne dans
le sud de la france une région qui a
donné lieu à des débordements au cours
des dernières semaines
comment ça se déroule actuellement où
vous êtes
mais là on n'est pas du tout essoufflé
on est vraiment un bon paquet il faut
pas croire les médias français qui nous
met des bâtons dans les roues
le mouvement est vraiment pas du tout
les soufflets on est en croissance
je dirais donc vouliez qu'un
essoufflement quand on regarde les
images en direct quand même à paris on
parle de quelques centaines de
manifestants actuellement et oui je vois
bien j'ai regardé un peu vite rythme fm
c'est vrai que apparemment la moitié et
je les jantes sont coincés dans les rues
donc exprès pour montrer à la télé comme
quoi on était super mais on n'est pas du
tout soufflé faut pas croire les médias
français est ce que vous êtes plutôt est
divisée monsieur coutard parce qu'il ya
quand même la frange des gilets jaunes
libre qui eux ont appelé à un dialogue
plutôt qu'à la manifestation en ce
samedi
oui enfin y'en a qui se sont mis porte
parole tout seul on va dire y'en a qui
oublient leurs vidéos qui a balancé
l'histoire mais en fait compte ils ont
vite retourné leur veste et ça c'est pas
bon donc on n'a rien gagné on a juste
mis la balle au centre maintenant il
faut pas lâcher
donc on écoute notre voie propre
les jaunes qui s'endort c'est ce qui
compte
elle ne le maquereau a promis plusieurs
mesures comme vous le savez là pour
tenter de calmer la colère des gilets
jaunes
visiblement ça ne vous suffit pas parce
que vous avez réclamé vous que les gens
sortent encore aujourd'hui qu'est ce que
vous réclamez exactement mais pas du
tout jamais les mesurettes qui l'a donné
c'est des miettes
ça concerne pas tout le monde et c'était
on va dire il a donné des acquis qu'il
avait déjà prévu donc maintenant il a
rien donner du tout il n'y a encore
menti comme d'habitude donc non nous on
veut le riz qui on veut plein de choses
et ils le savent très bien ce qu'on veut
encore temps de le répéter ils le savent
très bien
est-ce que vous réclamer la démission du
président franchement au cas où il en
est il ne sert plus à grand-chose à
faire bien servir sa cause lui propres
bon sens qu'il ya quand même des
mouvements autour de vous quand je
regarde les dépêches de la fp on parle
de 16 mille personnes qui manifestent
actuellement dans toute la france avec
environ 200 points de blocages de routes
quand on fait le calcul quand même c'est
beaucoup moins que les dernières
semaines mais aussi aussi 230 milles
dans les dernières semaines et c'est
coûteux mais les chiffres franchement à
la télé on a vraiment du mal à y croire
parce que là aujourd'hui à narbonne on
était de 2000 là des gens donc il faut
pas écouter les médias français en fait
on se bat contre les banquiers le
gouvernement et les médias français
c'est vraiment gros problème on a trois
ennemi de taille et on fait comme on
peut mais on lâche pas donc les alléger
les gens qui sont assortis sont ceux qui
qui réclame encore plus l'actuel plus de
mesures de la part des manuels maquereau
ou tout simplement elle sa démission
est ce que vous croyez que ça peut
donner encore lieu à des actes de
violence au cours des prochaines heures
c'est pas qu'on demande plus c'est qu'on
demande la justesse il a rien donné donc
on a en demande même pas plus sur
demande tout court
est-ce qu'il est beau c'est l'instar
d'autres narbonne c'est la star de la
mode
oui mais voilà mais c'est plus tard vous
vous avez rapidement été connue pendant
la france très rapidement avec la vidéo
vous avez lancé au mois d'octobre alors
que vous n'aviez jamais nécessairement
pris part à des manifestations c'est
exact jamais jamais jamais je suis on
aurait dit un jour que je serais en
train de manifester
non franchement j'étais pas dans la
situation encore recours pour manifester
mais je pense à tous mes amis mes
proches et tous qui sont dans des
situations difficiles
la moindre panne la moindre panne de
voiture à fribourg qui paye t tout et ça
nous fout dans le jus il mettre six mois
sans lever donc non il faut pas lâcher
faut se battre pour la justesse
est ce que vous dénoncez quand même les
actes de violence qui ont eu lieu au
cours des dernières semaines mais c'est
coûteux moi je ne cautionne pas la
violence à la haine et la violence si on
regarde bien que côté médias c'est
l'egypte qui foutent le bordel mais si
on regarde bien les crs sont pas tendres
avec nous ils ont bâton facile et très
très facile mais est ce que vous
attendez à ce que ça dégénère
aujourd'hui également non sur paris il a
mis tout ce qui pouvait donc mis son lit
ils ont bloqué déjà les 3 300 km en
paris déjà ils sont bloqués et fouillé
donc non il ya trop peu de débordements
je pense pas très bien là on continue de
suite bien sûr va la situation juste un
coup tard merci d'avoir été avec nous en
direct de narbonne dans le sud de la
france
merci à vous et bonne continuation et
merci de relayer les vraies informations
parce que la france on est vraiment bas
et côté parlé dans les médias jouent pas
du tout à l'égout
pas du tout ils sont vraiment contrôler
ni au revoir mais c'est plus tard merci